en los vídeos anteriores hablamos de
fronteras de las posibilidades de
producción relativamente estáticos algo
que no podemos cambiar pero que podemos
mover lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo
es pensar en que quizá haya maneras de
cambiar o expandir la frontera de
posibilidades de producción para hacer
esto vamos a asumir que nuestro pequeño
cazador recolector se ha vuelto un
completo carnívoro y ahora solo se
enfoca en conejos y su mayor felicidad
en la vida es optimizar el número de
conejos que puede atrapar y comer en un
día vamos a dibujar aquí un par de ejes
más o menos derechos
en un eje vamos a dibujar el número de
conejos que puede atrapar en un solo día
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y bueno esto puede
continuar indefinidamente
3 4 5 6 7
pero recuerden que quiere optimizar
quiere pensar en cómo incrementar su
productividad en términos de número de
conejos así que esto es
lejos
conejos por
y nosotros asumimos que él sabe cómo
hacer trampas para conejos así que ahora
haremos una frontera de posibilidades de
producción pero en esta ocasión no será
entre conejos y bayas sino entre la
construcción de trampas para conejos en
este eje vamos a poner el número de
trampas que puede hacer en un día
estas son trampas
conejos
lejos
ok aquí puede hacer una trampa dos
trampas y su límite para hacer trampas
en un día son tres
a lo mejor consigue herramientas y las
une para hacer algún tipo de tejido de
pared o de caja
y con esta
caja
pone aquí a lo mejor pone un tipo de no
sé de zanahoria que le atrae a los
conejos
y la pone de manera que cuando algún
conejo trata de llevarse esta zanahoria
la caja le cae encima
y lo atrapa
a hacer un poquito más grande para que
quepa el conejo
pero también puede pasar todo su tiempo
construyendo trampas para conejos
y digamos que todas las demás cosas se
van a mantener igual para no
preocuparnos por ellas en la mayoría de
las clases de introducción a la economía
siempre que se hace una frontera de
posibilidades de producción siempre se
hace en dos dimensiones y es por eso que
se obtiene una curva regular pero se
podría tener una de tres dimensiones en
donde se puede operar con tres cosas
pero deberán tener una gráfica
tridimensional y la frontera de
posibilidades de producción sería una
superficie pero por ahora enfoca menos
en este ejemplo más adelante podremos
hacer una superficie sólo por diversión
digamos que la frontera de posibilidades
de producción entre las trampas para
conejo estas trampas
los conejos va a haber si así este señor
puede pasar todo su tiempo haciendo
trampas para conejos pero el problema es
que no va a tener tiempo para que hacer
ningún conejo y moriría de hambre lo
cual no es un buen escenario o puede
pasar todo su tiempo cazando conejos en
donde atrapa un promedio de 5 conejos
por día pero eso no le deja tiempo para
hacer trampas para conejos por lo que
está más o menos sería nuestra curva
más o menos algo
sí
nuestra curva de fronteras de
posibilidades de producción la vamos a
llamar
frontera de posibilidades de producción
subíndice 0 porque es nuestra condición
inicial así que su eficiencia de
producción se puede asentar en cualquier
parte de esta curva pero como vimos si
el pasa todo su tiempo cazando conejos
nunca podría hacer trampas para
atraparlos y no podrá cambiar la
frontera de posibilidades de producción
pero qué pasa si él decide hacer algunas
trampas para conejos por lo que
decremento
el número de conejos que atrapa por día
a 4 y eso le permite construir una
trampa de conejos al día así que ahora
se va a encontrar en este escenario así
que en promedio atrapa cuatro conejos y
hace una trampa por día que es lo que va
a pasar pues conforme transcurre el
siguiente periodo o el siguiente día él
va a tener una trampa después de un día
por lo que podrá usarla para atrapar
conejos por lo que esto cambiará la
curva de la frontera si él hace esta
inversión le permitirá en cierto tiempo
atrapar más conejos al hacer esto no se
incrementará el número de trampas que
pueda hacer en un día así que ésta se va
a mantener en tres pero quizás ahora
pueda atrapar seis conejos por día por
lo que ahora la curva de frontera va a
verse más o menos
más o menos así
así que ahora puede dejar de hacer
trampas de conejos y cazar seis de ellos
al día con una trampa que tiene o puedes
seguir haciendo una trampa al día por lo
que ahora podría cazar cinco conejos al
día y construir una trampa en ese mismo
día puede caer en cualquiera de estos
elementos de la curva y ahora a esta
curva
la voy a llamar frontera de
posibilidades de producción 1 porque es
después de un día
puede decir que está contento atrapando
cuatro conejos al día y ahora se
dedicará a hacer dos trampas de conejo
dos trampas de conejo
al día
aunque quizá esté exagerando en lo
rápido que puedes construir sus trampas
pero quizás ahora la curva de la
frontera de producción
y va más o menos acá si puede hacer dos
trampas le permita cazar quizás ahora
ocho conejos al día entonces
puede dedicarse a cazar más conejos o
puede ser alguna combinación intermedia
esta nueva curva
frontera de producción se vería más o
menos así y ésta
te voy a llamar
frontera de posibilidades de producción
2 porque es después del segundo día lo
que hace este cazador recolector en este
escenario de aquí es hacer una inversión
está acumulando capital esta trampa de
acá
es capital aunque usted no lo crea
capital
está eligiendo en lugar de sólo consumir
todos sus recursos está invirtiendo
pueda elegir pasar su tiempo consumiendo
obtenido tantos conejos como sea posible
y después comérselos todos o pueda
elegir reducir su consumo y dedicar
algunos de sus recursos en inversiones
así que esto de aquí este eje de las
trampas de conejo esto son inversiones
una inversión
inversión
y lo hace más productivo este eje
horizontal de acá
este eje será de consumo consumo
hay un nivel básico de consumo que
necesita para sobrevivir pero si
invierte va a incrementar su capacidad
de producción general si lo viéramos
como una economía en sí mismo al
invertir en lugar de consumir todos sus
recursos sus recursos en este caso son
tiempo y conocimiento al invertir alguno
de ellos puede incrementar su
productividad si lo viéramos como una
economía él tendría un crecimiento
crecimiento
económico
hay muchos tipos de inversión de las
cuales hablaremos en el futuro en este
caso él está acumulando capital
construye herramientas que lo hacen más
productivo otro tipo de inversión es el
cambio o mejoramiento tecnológico que
mejoraría sus herramientas por ejemplo
en la investigación y desarrollo para
tener mejores herramientas que le
permitan tener mejores casas pero lo que
quiero que vean es que la frontera de
posibilidades si se puede cambiar uno
puede volverse más productivo si se
invierte en investigación y desarrollo
fue la acumulación de capital como en
este caso que se trata de trampas de
conejo